when stranger things debuted on Netflix
in 2016 it brought a brand new
generation of bright young stars into
the Hollywood spotlights the acclaimed
sci-fi series continued this passim with
the second season by tacking new
characters max Mayfield and Billy
Hargrove onto the stranger things roster
and giving the actors who played them a
shot at Netflix backed super stardom the
man behind the callous yet cool bad boy
Billy caught many fans eyes on season 2
& 3 and as billies personal Ark became
more complex his performance grew
increasingly captivating I'm waiting to
meet this king Steve everybody's been
telling me so much about viewers
couldn't help but feel that his striking
looks were oddly familiar so who is the
man behind Billy Hargrove it's daycare
Montgomery an Australian actor and poet
who had only a handful of credits under
his belt before securing the role of
Billy on stranger things
there was filmography a short there are
a few projects Montgomery has been in
the fans were recognized born in Perth
Western Australia to Canadian mother
Judith barrett-lennard and New Zealand
her father Scott Montgomery Harvey
Montgomery began pursuing acting when he
was still a child an interest partly
fostered by his parents who were both in
the film industry my mom worked in the
film issue for 20 years she was
production coordinator at my dad's still
the sound recordist and I'm lucky that I
had that background and fall in love
with it he explained a little more about
that background at a march 2017
interview with Teen Vogue saying they
both work behind the camera so I like to
think that I have a really good
understanding of how all the parts of
the puzzle come together to make a film
or TV show I always wanted to get into
acting I've been pursuing that for a
long time Montgomery continued to
explore his passion in his adolescence
then honed his talents throughout his
adulthood by completing an acting degree
through the Western Australian Academy
of Performing Arts at Edith Cowan
University
this led Montgomery to roles in short
films like Bertrand the terrible and
godot's clinic as well as he Australian
flick a few less men a follow-up to the
comedy from Down Under entitled a few
best men those experiences then set him
on the road to a big break which came
with a 2017 Power Rangers reboots
Montgomery also appeared as Jason
Scott's better known as a Red Ranger
it's morphin time
audience says were so impressed with the
new kid on the block that they came
together to vote for him at the 2017
Teen Choice Awards for his performance
as a Red Ranger Montgomery scored a
nomination for choice sci-fi movie actor
but sadly lost out to guardians of the
galaxy volume 2 star Chris Pratt's after
taking a turn as a Mighty Morphin Power
Ranger Montgomery appeared as Jeremy in
the Christmas themed horebeek better
watch out described by critics as quote
an ingenious and efficient black comic
shocker bolstered by its charismatic
cast
now if Montgomery screen work isn't the
reason why you look so familiar to you
you might be a music-themed with an
affinity for Australian music and the
fantastic memory in 2015 Montgomery
appeared in the music video for old
souls by Perth heavy metal band make
them suffer he circled back to the music
scene in 2017 for indie folk group Angus
& Julia stones at Chateau video of
course Montgomery is best known as Billy
on stranger things and season 3 saw him
just play a much wider range of talent
that's sure to keep him in hollywood's
eye for a long time to come next up for
the actor is just incur sales film a
true history of the Kelly Gang said
Montgomery's mug will remain on screens
everywhere for the foreseeable future
Storage Montgomery fans can also tune in
to the actors podcast dkh for which he
collaborated with musicians to bring his
poetry to life check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite stuff
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and to the pal so you don't miss
a single one
[Music]